We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two. David, here. Here's a really
interesting story, which, if I understand
it correctly, we're going to listen to it.
A mom was able to better help her daughter
thanks to The David Pakman Show, I think.
Let's listen to this together. A beautiful story.
Hey, David. So I just kind of wanted to just give
you some major props and kind of the changes
you've made in my life. My daughter to eighteen.
She's a senior high school, just a college
student in the last couple of years
anyway. So she called me a few minutes ago and was
like, I have the psychology paper in college to do
at the end of the month. I have no idea what
to do with it because it's too overwhelming.
And I just I don't think I'll be able to do
this, just kind of having a little bit of panic.
And so I said, OK, well, let's write this down
piece by piece and I want to throw with her.
And it wasn't until the very end that I
realized that the way that you analyze things is
really what gave me the skills to be
able to talk to her. And we tell you
at the end of it she felt completely confident.
Wow. Because she knew what she was doing on paper
and she was able to break it down and and, you
know, look at each aspect of the paper without
actually, like looking at the entire picture of.
And I just want to say thank you. I think that
watching your program and being a member and all
that, I've really got a smile is my daughter's
life. And yeah, I appreciate everything you did.
Wow.
That is an unbelievable voice mail. I love that.
I don't I guess I guess what she's saying is just
sequentially breaking down what's going on and not
being overwhelmed when a ton of stuff is thrown at
you. I think that that's what she's saying was
useful. I love that. I really appreciate the
kind words. Maybe there is more to say about it on
today's bonus show. Yes, we will hear about Pat's
spring break. We will also hear about mine. And I
have stories of deep nose swaps. I have stories of
humiliating Americans around the
world doing embarrassing things.
I have stories of what it's like to fly during
the pandemic. It's just stories. A lot a lot of
stories to tell on today's bonus show. Get instant
access, truly instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joined Pakman Dotcom or by
becoming a patron at Patreon dot com slash David
Pakman show. Those are the two ways to get instant
access to the bonus show. We will see you then.
We are back. We have great shows
and streams and bonus shows coming.
And what I guess that's. Really, the full
story, I don't know if I don't have anything
else to promote specifically, but it's great to
be back and we will be back with you tomorrow.
But the bonus show starts really
right now if you're a member of the.